live hey everybody welcome to Monday
melee yeah oh man thank you for joining
us uh we're back after two weeks which
is crazy I can hear myself on that phone
actually if there's a something weird
over there hey how's everybody doing
with with us is always bet Morosky in
the chat
Jason O'Malley creeper in the corner and
new creeper in the corner we'll Becton
thank you for joining us today we're
playing Super Mario maker cuz yesterday
was the yesterday was the 30th or 35th
anniversary of Mario I don't know that's
right strong strong bag croc white after
Labor Day
I'm a fashion rebel everybody also 30th
30th anniversary also on no socks no
well the low socks at high shoes hey
magic man groovy boat Edgar ask scary
Mack shady fridge what's going on peas
music good to see you guys all right
here we go we're gonna play some Super
Mario maker and and we're gonna make the
levels you guys want to see on this yeah
so far it's exactly like regular Mario
maybe it's having us play the first
level so we know it works with oh wait a
second it's up to us to to complete it
cool all right
how do we do this whoa cool wow this is
great height pipe
shadows magic Madison we turn on that
light here we go Oh weird
wait what do we do here wait what am I
supposed to do this is crazy
well I see this is where we start all
right gun guns min T V good to see you
big square alright so we can move the
camera all around
okay the shadows in the game not on our
faces yes yeah doesn't the game but it's
good that we have good key lighting here
alright drag has something to keep it
inside
so what's what kind of course should we
make you guys I mean after I do this
tutorial I drag stuff here we go I see I
get it I get it
Oh use the pen thanks guys
got my old pen here oh and by the way
just then I wear this shirt for you guys
you have nothing nice to say then we
have a lot in common but let's all keep
it positive day alright pull down the
items to South Dakota gamer says ok
pulling down the items now is reading in
preparation ok I got it
oh I see I see I'm gonna put one in here
going in here I was reading some
theories about Super Mario and the world
of Super Mario did you know actually in
the instruction manual for Super Mario
Brothers it says people the Mushroom
Kingdom their souls have been put into
the blocks so when you're destroying
blocks you're actually destroying people
in the game and somebody said it does
that mean that their that their souls
are the gold coins
so actually Mario is is harvesting souls
whoa yeah pretty crazy right pretty
crazy so let's see here so uh alright
let's see we don't like it I gotta put
put one of these in here got it let's
move the camera oh and then what do I
put a pipe here to go up here I see does
that mean it's a double pipe by the way
very nice fingernails but that's not
actually that's not my hand whoa weird
is that what it does that's crazy to me
I should have put this inside here I
don't know what I'm doing this is gonna
be the most effed up level ever by the
way
Mario is the Grand plumber that's true
yeah it's true Grand plumber shaking
elements touch and hold and then shake
it from side to side whoa
oh I see how it changes okay so you
change stuff that's pretty dope now do I
have to finish this whole level to do
this or what's the deal putting this in
here
all right this is great I just want to
get making a crazy level well I'm super
drunk as I always have
yeah you're wrong yeah there's five loco
it's a new thing I made I put four look
I put four loko and I added another loco
which means cocaine that's what I'm
talking about
oh my god I have to put all these blocks
here is there a way to just put a lot of
blocks somewhere follow these blocks
over here it was like you're almost done
oh my God Jesus I think oh okay yeah oh
yes Cinco loco gotta make the first
intro level and save it - I have to save
it Jesus Christ see I should have done
this before we started sorry I don't
know what that it what am I doing here
isn't it tap and hold oh I see oh
whatever selected I can just I can just
tap it oh by the way this is a preview
of how bad my actual levels gonna hit
him all right perfect we did it now what
how do we actually do it putting wings
on things oh I see got it hey put a wing
on it you know great done so am I done
or what's the deal oh whoops
ah you why is a dog on dude that doesn't
make any sense
all right what is this oh I don't want
to race all right how do we be done how
do we be done yeah ah Conan has one inch
on me dude has one inch on me so no I'm
not unfortunately although I'd like to
be because he constantly looms over me
and uses his height as a emotional
advantage dog-ate-my-homework has a
hilarious comment if you like it then
you should have put a wing on it woo
it's my favorite see very box a little
wing we're done here we're done we're
done
we'd be done how do we be done with this
level Jesus God
how do I get out of Super Mario how do
we do this also what's this G down here
swims the camera how do we hey guys how
do we be done done go back the ass in
the bottom and click play oh I see okay
quick play whoops apparently the way to
go level is Corner riot that's all
that's what I'm seeing tap there's some
yeah there's some serious sound effects
how's your course looking well like [ __ ]
alright here we go oh so this thing
alright now the play comes up alright
let's go
[Music]
so far our champion just getting those
souls now think about when you make your
up oh my god
think about when you make your own level
is there's no surprises yeah like beYOU
homeschool nailed it
boom alright we did it guys you're ready
to make our level it's gonna be awesome
I don't want to timeout people but if
the spamming keeps happening yeah
Beth will have no other job that's gonna
ban you guys do it I should ban bring
down the path hammer select a slot world
one yup did nail bun nailed it you two
question of why you don't ever fight
back Coenen uh cuz I would I would lose
my job now I don't fight back because I
don't want to hurt the guy you know yeah
I injure him that I can't do a show I'm
all her hurting you guys alright here we
go new icons are available all right
let's do it
don't cross this don't cross nothin to
you exactly alright how do I get out of
here
woo whoa cool all right here we go guys
time for uh how do we go back to the
beginning here we already played it here
anyone
whoa awesome this is great all right
let's make a new level all right new
combo should we start with this what's
this reset yeah all right great
all right here we go guys now what is
your favourite piece what's your
favorite piece do you like a block do
you like a turtle
what if I put some turtles down here but
first of all should we go Super Mario
you or Super Mario Brothers maybe we
start classic let's start class ah next
2:30 yes is the first time play Super
Mario maker beat haven't cracked it open
till just now and it's great and it's
clear yes whoa sweet course world look
what somebody did on Facebook your face
what do they do see the magic happening
there such magic oh we don't care about
this what am i doing I don't how do I
get out of here I don't care about this
I don't want to wait all right so I
think let's make a let's make a level
hmm
blue melons I'm I knew here had blue
melons thanks for joining us whoa
courses guys have you've made other
courses if you've made courses let us
know so we can play them just start your
course with Team Coco all right I don't
care about this let's make a course
ourselves all right
but you guys please make a course on
Super Mario maker and maybe we can even
get Conan to play yeah that'd be great
just start it with Team Coco start the
name of team Coco and then tweet at us
and let us know that you did it and
hashtag Monday Meili I have not my
friend Casey has and it's incredible
Metal Gear Solid phantom pain all right
I'm gonna what if I put ahh let's see
what do you think let's just start with
a base right
what do we think make a quarter
let's see you would not make of course
until all hail Conan close Karen Mario
maker would be fun to know besides your
hipster guy with t-shirt I don't know
that's that hipster got a t-shirt
ooh really looking forward to fallout 4
we'll all fall out I'm really looking
forward to we're some other great games
coming out I don't know follow four I
love that and the next the next Skyrim
whatever that is in 50 years okay I'm
all about that bass you know it let's
see where he's music and friller an
alien solution than you nice
there's bet plenty games Lucas Beth does
play some games oh cool Tom thanks for
hosting us all right yeah we could play
other people's levels actually the dread
so let us know what level you you made
and we'll play Final Fantasy 7 remake
would be dub I never played the first
one set I'm I'm gonna go back and play
all their Uncharted games but I try
before it looks amazing
alright let's get to making this level
right oh it's the next Elder Scrolls
you're right of a gaming half-life 3 is
never gonna come out so all right I'm
gonna put some some coins here just to
make myself feel good you know start off
the level good I that looks kind of like
a whale so let's make a whale out of
coins this is gonna show it a terrible
terrible artist I am no this kind of
looks like a whale right
coin whale hashtag coin whale it's
pretty good
let's see here let's go over this way
alright before we get to the coin coin
well though we're gonna have to earn it
can we shake this into something nope
alright
looks like a dead turkey the whale but
it kinda I'm sure this is exactly what
everybody does by the way the first time
we do yeah and it's super cool
[Music]
how are you watching us guys look at all
these flying to get to the coin well
we're gonna have to what's gonna happen
with all these guys jumping around I
wonder right cone with the coins that's
a good idea uh who said that like Cody
with the coins
yeah dread the draft thank you I'm right
coming up here at the coins someone said
my mom would even buy a coin we'll talk
about that wow what was she doing in the
coin ocean is the better question oh my
god that doesn't look like Kona at all
damn it use the bouncy thing that's next
to the mushroom what does that mean does
that look like Conan nope there we go
that's kind of close right yeah exactly
yeah this is looking like something that
we have to prove our identity with that
counts yeah kind of take this one out
this one this one oops
there we go that's that's counted I
think that was a coin and nail it whoa
nailed it high-five put your hand up to
the screen good job Oh fat fat Houdini I
live in Germany I love you guys we love
you too I love Germany best beer in the
biz all right I'll see you nailed it
let's see is this what it's look this
what it's like to work in television
yes BK go back to Hawaii
my friend Brian King who actually stole
the ticket sign for the Tonight Show
after after the the rally was over yes
apartment I have a cool mustache this is
actually called a beard a mustache is
just on top the beard is the whole thing
so this is a beard just a mustache let's
put it let's put some stuff in here I
wonder let's make a gauntlet let's make
a gauntlet of of pipes this is gonna be
nice and difficult I think make this go
up there we go
I don't always I always hate the pipes
cuz they lead to a different world that
you don't you don't know about you know
okay
next course some ones are gonna arrive
tomorrow if that noise wanna make a huge
thing of pipes to pipe heaven how do I
we're getting shot us from Europe
Malaysia yeah everywhere that's a long a
lot of places all right now we're gonna
put these things in here right how to
make them come up at different times
that's all I know
oh come on Diedrich really I think well
look at that whale there negging us cuz
they like that whale
alright now let you know what you know
it's all right it's always been fun is
when you run acrost like the whole thing
you know you ever do that you just go
really fast across the whole thing a
speed run let's try to do that oh this
is debts as long as the course could be
you know you never get to do is go up
super high in these games so let's go up
like real high I'm gonna see if Mario
can make it past this yeah New Jersey
actually you know when I saw Bayonne New
Jersey has an amazing uh tributes that
Putin gave America do you know about
that no throw the teardrop monument
giving from Vladimir Putin personally to
America and we put it in Bayonne New
Jersey
I love BAM New Jersey I'm just saying
you could have put it in New York that's
kind of like passive-aggressive on our
part of thing yeah I throw in the Denver
Airport but I'm gonna put some guys in
here you know put some fellas in here
just to make it interesting you know
this is I'm calling this scorch trials
this is the Maze Runner scorch trouser
you haven't seen that page runners Port
Charles movie this is what happens in it
you don't need to watch it cuz you're
about to see me play Maze Runner scorch
trials and I'm gonna put some stuff
around here just to make things
interesting oh yeah this is gonna do
it's can I put a wing on a mushroom I
can oh that's great oh man check this
out so many wings on things wings on
things now I know chicken wings taste
good a buffalo wings taste good I wonder
how mushroom wings taste probably effing
disgusting I don't like a mushroom I
don't like mushrooms and a mushroom with
a wing is I don't know something
horrifying that's what we're destroying
our environment so that's probably bad
all right I'm doing it
wait let's uh put some other
I'm gonna make it hard on these guys
that means to pick up bounce around and
stuff you know just getting some to plan
on the other like cats basically oh god
what's that fanny I call Finland Finny
just respect for pals close camera
status were taping a new one on
Wednesday very exciting whoo
it's gonna be incredibly fun all right I
think we're ready to play yo let's play
it yeah oh this is kind of rough oh in
your face bet you never believed in us
so you think I didn't put any work into
this but I
oh Jesus oh man does that get the coin
for me no if I get killed on my own
level is gonna be embarrassing oh Jesus
Christ
they're gonna come back playing again
Jesus this is odd
why did I put so many guys over here ah
swap a perv
how can he send us his code to play his
level well what's that yeah is your name
swap a pair of how do we find it
let's go
Jesus I'm getting a lot of points I
don't mean to toot my horn but I can't
beat my hello oh you know I have a good
idea
watch this what's this okay you know let
me finish this level first Lieut fish as
well for me it just starts wherever you
die I guess oh my god do they come up if
you're standing on them they do it right
all right scorch trials here we go
scorch trials how do I want to get
around here why it makes such a hard
level god yeah I got it input codes
thanks Nintendo for the backwards way I
just put your code over here yeah honor
thing I guess sweet about to kill myself
yeah one up on the other side alright
now they all right now I want to make
the one that's all jumping things and
see if I can just get past it alright
we're gonna save this one is the whale
here we go oh yeah fissile put it but
fizzle put theirs up copy that
coin whale
oh great yeah for it up for them have
you guys yeah give us your codes and
we'll play them are gonna reset it
alright here's something I've always
wanted to see it why is that Nintendo
here we go here we go baby alright the
game here is gonna be very simple
okay the game here is very simple
survive or die is there an option to
change your drawing into a zombie that's
cool like if you could changed oh that
would be awesome
oh did someone was saying I was making
fun of the codes they said they don't
want dirty words and the code names make
them random Oh or they could just make
yeah make it really cool could just not
be terrible well that's not true no what
am I saying in a theater now people are
going
for cat paw
I can make the level longer you say yeah
perfect well we're not gonna want this
one longer I call this the gauntlet
that's right baby
I'm gonna don't worry I'm gonna give
Mario
I'll give him I'll give him some rights
and mushrooms now this actually I was
just kidding about the scorch trials
before but if you haven't seen the Maze
Runner spoiler alert this is exactly
what happens in it he just goes up
against a lot of red shells I don't know
how they got the licensing from Nintendo
but it was great see it gets harder as
you go on because these guys all fly I'm
saying to the beginning all right here
we go guys you're ready I'm writing down
all your codes by the way beth is taking
all the codes down so don't worry all
right here we go hope you guys are ready
there we go guys the gauntlet you ready
all right now I'm gonna put some
mushrooms in here too just to make it
all easier who's your favorite Mario
characters whoo I like um while Luigi's
kind of cool cuz I think he's just a
crazed Mario fan I don't think he's like
an enemy I actually read this crazy this
crazy theory that said the only real
mario game in reality was the first one
and then the rest of them are all Mario
reliving his former glory of beating
Bowser is that great already the
gauntlet let's go nope
all right the key is gonna be to get
that mushroom let's go oh god they're up
here alright here we go
no I'm gonna do it I'm gonna do you know
what I do first so just to give myself a
little help I'm gonna put a mushroom
over here just in case
alright now let's play oh no the most
remote away alright here's my my
strategy nailed this guy okay the wrong
way that's great
but wait till another one comes over
here and then bobbum oh Jesus I was yeah
alright I can do this guy's gauntlet the
gauntlet here we go I'm gonna start him
right here alright there we go now we're
a little bit better territory here
alright I'm gonna buy my time see me of
that killed zero Jesus no no why did I
crouch the other thing is like oh nice
playing this perfectly the other thing
is I'm playing on a gamepad I'm not used
to the game all my Mario skills have
been done on a normal controller
I can't get that mushroom yet no I don't
want the mushroom oh Jesus
oh my god there's so many of them there
you go here we go
no stop getting the mushrooms I need
them okay we're doing okay by the way
how horrifying with these Oh Shh I
should see you guys didn't believe I
could do it I still can't here we go
here we go we're doing okay we're doing
okay all right what do we think I think
I can am I gonna get murdered if I try
to kill this dude nope
yeah see they come back after I've
killed them which is nice oh there is
but it's the it's how wide it is apart
that's screwing me up man all right here
we go it's gonna be tough Mario game huh
I have just I haven't played a lot of
gauntlet we haven't played I played zero
gallons in my life here we go here we go
oh this is gonna be tough you guys I
think I got to knock that guy off there
right is there an echo from over there I
can hear an echo there's something going
on over there Oh knows how loud you have
the headphones turned over how loud am I
talking is the better question very loud
yes all right here we go first level
cleared here comes the gullet no this is
how do I attack this
[Music]
I'm just going in I almost did it I
almost did it you guys I gotta complete
the garland all right do we after the
gauntlet I'm gonna play I'm gonna play
play some fan fan boards here I'm just
making a run for it here we go can I get
through yes the gauntlet Oh speed run
gauntlet
you just gotta live you just gotta go
for it that's what it got looks no fear
no fear in the god
no fear who said that thank you Oh God
God could be a slave to corporate
America bet gauntlet that's how you do
the gauntlet ladies and gentlemen all
right let's play some fan play some fan
stuff I'm gonna save the gauntlet here
look no that's skill baby hey if you
have nothing nice to say then we have
something in common all right so how do
we play so we go up here and then we
horse world horse world
all right so what are some codes so I
think it's up here yeah all right give
me the give me the first code okay how
about yeah just tell me what it is
DEP one zero zero zero zero zero zero
three four five one five five and whose
is this I don't know
perfect all right well somebody's we're
about to play yours tell us this is
yours tell us Slippery inferno yeah
that's mine out there all right here we
go
all right slippery inferno let's do it
O'Brien
okay Brian Brian American Brian whoo
American Brian already I'm diggin his
music
whoa I love this already American Brian
oh hey it's Kate Kate AED Katie uh oh
geez ice all right the problem it's no
problem
we got a free life member it's
everyone's
it was fizzles next time
Beth will write down next time thought
through write down who's these are wait
a second we'll see I touched the screen
to play too much wine how do I be a
success
oh the the ice is a [ __ ] so you know
it's a little tough here is we have the
we have the ice mixed with I hate those
guys got the ice mixed with the regular
stuff so take a Pokemon oh now we're
excited what is going on here can we
kill this thing all right
oh my god this is rough I'm just thanks
to whoever said bless you
yeah go down here there's nothing for us
down here there's nothing but death none
even death oh geez I see you go you can
with fireballs okay
thanks little trickster kid this is
harder the golly what else in the
gauntlet took me
what about 45 seconds to me also they
come all right I just want to get kind
of far the ice is screw me up yeah Devin
you should be watching this at work and
thank you for watching this at work you
know I hate I hate the zombie the zombie
things the most what if that person that
made it can just tell us and no one else
does anything what what are you saying
oh I see I think I have to knock them on
the head this is gonna go very poorly
oh wow you can oh is this is like Super
Mario 3 star something I'll give me a
dollar if I what oh thanks who's that oh
come on flying ones can I go up here
what it's just a trick all right that
was a trick we're gonna have a problem I
don't know the kinds of things you could
do in this game finally I'll take a
dollar I'll take a dollar
awesome it was 9 K 1 give us that dollar
Whalers are niceties top of their heads
wrong little trickster kid they're not
nice cuz they killed me when they didn't
stop on their head alright give me
another one I think it really was
fizzles oh great level fizzle how do we
know it's thinking which is fantastic
pay the man soggy hustle Mack says yep
dollar menu only three deaths Sargent
sport says that's not bad sending dollar
now says Henry uh it was fizzle right I
think fizzle great map that was really
fun alright hit us with another thing
here how do we I don't know sorry
slippery inferno whoa please itself
alright let's check it out it's gonna be
a virus that infects our system it plays
itself and your whole system and your
database and gets your stuff all right
read me the code maybe the code 1616 5 5
F F for zeros okay this is just this
credit card yeah double 0 32 6 D
9e this sounds like a great whose is
this whose is this good lice alright
dude likes for playing your map next now
it plays itself what does that mean it
plays itself it's just so easy to put
Top Thrill Dragster don't move it says
okay
oh you don't move alright I'm not gonna
move hands up
Bessel aw is that from Sweden what map
is that Wow
cool oh this is awesome this is great oh
my god this is brilliant
look at this finally a level I could
beat seriously whoa this is insane
how what did it take to make this we're
just gonna dance oh my god now we're on
Yoshi yes wow that was really fun well
done well done
way to go doorway that was incredible
guys that was a really fun one play that
get play that one play that one yeah
let's all move to Norway that's
fantastic all right here's another so
what's another one what do you got for
me that's okay no these have names so
you can all take credit for all right so
we'll do one one a six nine good one
funny one yeah I'm sensing a pattern
with the second four numbers here
they're 300 or zero oh I'm sorry
five for FB perfect this one's mine Bray
wok says yeah yeah Sam well it's mine
it's our search thing yes little
trickster kid there is a search thing
but it's oh it's only done by numbers
Jeremy from Canada Canadian Jeremy do
you ever feel like a plastic bag he says
whoa okay hey Canadian Jeremy go [ __ ]
yourself how about that Wow Kamini
Jeremy hit me hard already with the
ghost just the ghost what I'm a kid he
all worked on this one together oh
nothing whoa what happened there oh my
god maybe Jeremy you're an a-hole okay
here we go
I turn into a child
all right let's we got it we just gotta
time this out can I get on those skulls
I can write Canadian Jeremy butcher how
do we even go here let's see let's
figure this out we're gonna jump there
then we're gonna jump up to that other
block then across this is ridiculous all
right we got a time all right kiddies
villager from smash you know I think
we're gonna sacrifice the villager when
we get up to the top the top there right
and we go perfect nailed it we did it
meaning Jeremy you and I are no longer
friends
Jesus oh I see you just got to jump
through the fire and kill the villager I
think is the idea it's not as true what
yeah this really played this one let's
go
does not play it's now starting to feel
bad for me to play a different dying
sign with the NBC sound and BC there we
go
I'm not afraid I'm just going for it the
thing is it's it's tough to time that
cuz the kid I guess we got to kill the
kid right it's so distracting to still
follow Super Mario here we go
yeah man tough to slow down over there
I'm going too fast I know better Nate
for the solo would have been where's
your God now
[Laughter]
exactly that's okay we're still alive
Jesus are you kidding me AHA now what go
up this is ridiculous nailed it right in
the log that's where I wanted to go I
wanted to come on it alright here we go
get the kid get the kid do the fire jump
on the thing kill yourself alright I'm
giving this chick two more tries two
more tries nightclub yeah alright two
more tries here we go ah American
capitalist yeah I think this game is
worth getting we're having fun with it
so far
[Music]
hey boy nice watch can I have it
nope you can't have it got it though
it's a penguin watch just got it this
weekend
penguin store 30 bucks here we go last
try let's try this is it guys that's it
we're done next one sorry well done also
where's your God now is the perfect
yeah that's right nightclub how do we do
a nightclub that was an interesting
level though we kind of have to
sacrifice your guy a bit alright yeah I
was going I was going too fast but it's
also you had to get over the beginning
you have to go fast what's the ce-1 a
585 you said zero zero three eight eight
B six five this is from invader invader
invader alright here we go
that's a bot somebody said yeah hey
Shane thanks for first time in the
stream thanks for joining us oh ain't
gay bro you don't need to sacrifice your
guy though well so far not like any
night now I can anything how about I
don't know what nightclubs you're going
to place is crazy Wow who's this DJ
nightclub my ass
I can take the shell down with me
neither wait live in this nightclub this
is awesome
best nightclub ever it oh my god this is
crazy what does that say Team Coco yeah
oh man awesome this is great
oh man this is a great level oh now
we're out of the neck
oh god the sun's so bright left the
nightclub yeah it's five eight oh I just
wanted yeah I was hungover after the
nightclub I can't wait to go back this
nightclub guys there's no wait
ladies night yes this is great love it
BAM oh man nightclub that was good ah
back to our jobs in the real world sucks
Oh
oh that was great Wow good job invader
well done it was great I loved it
difficult level of level jelly pausing
said all right what else we got guys
were playing reduce join us are playing
Super Mario maker yes there's the 30th
anniversary of Mario happy birthday
Mario the great adventure was a great
adventure so today we're playing your
Maps to celebrate the anniversary of
Mario yesterday oh we're playing the
30th anniversary of Mario yesterday we
are playing your Maps today so hit us
with the ID description and a little
description will help to Team Coco night
club is amazing
I'm Beth Lilith all the great adventure
all right Jo 0 2 F 4 4 6 8 awesome
and whose is this this is B / DF b / d s
love it b / Tommy gun's no color and has
not played this yet but hey B / Canadian
beeper beeps the great adventure let's
see how great this adventure truly is
whoa oh my god holy crap this looks
awesome
good question
jump on those guys French oh my god this
is crazy this is good we're gonna we're
gonna take some time for this one Justin
Bieber good one I look spooky levels no
I can grab these out of the air aah no
aah I do like getting in the middle of
those little thanks all right we're back
I'm just I'm going I'm gonna get this
[Music]
how do I get over that dr. B in the
middle of that it's my favorite
experience Luna ku asked what's my
favorite experience working here meeting
celebrities getting to hang out and do
comedy and all of our great friends that
we we have here on the show it's awesome
we're very lucky it's a good place to
work playing with you guys oh my god
the bouncer things are tough careful you
walk kratos says i love this game and
don't you have it just run alright we're
gonna ride come on that you have friends
at work if you were like really into
watching one lady
lie down watching the x-files do we just
want to actually there's probably like a
fetish this great read Victorian novels
actually watching Miss robots robots
fantastic
everybody watch mr. robot it's a great
show
hey Asha bra thank you for your awesome
love perfect just kill myself my shirt
says if you have nothing nice to say we
have a lot in common
I'm just running I'm running let's do it
I'm getting through it I think you just
gotta power through that part perfect
damn it
King piss you should get a wiiu and get
this game it's incredible thank you get
me on that thing the key is to kind of
go a little fast I think it's just Erin
Blair yeah oh Jesus
oh my god what is happening over Wow all
right this guy's got bouncing around a
little bit how is this gonna work this
thing can I jump over all this what do
we think I could do it ah cameras get a
little close I think we use worth it
yeah you guys a lot of really fun
collaborative games and creative games
[Applause]
hey come on alright alright alright
alright oh I find this music very
soothing
yes platoon is really fun too on the Wii
U I mean you got your Mario Kart got a
whole bunch of great stuff whoa easy
I've always loved how Mario stops on a
dime yeah hey ho oh that's bad right
that's very bad oh this is extremely bad
Jim Jim Jim didn't see that coming did
you didn't see that coming ah Oh what's
happening why is there work ah what's
happening
no no what's happening what happened
it's warp I got a star way back here
scheme could use some extra like
starting points I mean the studio at our
house we are in the studio which we live
at so it's also our house yeah exactly I
hate that guy gotta get away from this
dude hate this dude hate that dude new
level alright new level people are
saying new level alright last time in
this level little speed run through here
last time yeah we've got we but we just
downloaded this this morning if that
person near you your way now the answer
is where's your brother fan although I
keep asking I started to run through
this I'm gonna get yeah you know what I
bet I can jump on the hammer bro right
what what what what where do i what no
no the maze love the maze yeah let's
play some let's play some the maze ah
canadian beeper well done
if i could fight a duck sized horse or a
horse size 100 horse sized duck a duck
sized horse that's you're asking that
question wrong like no you wanna what
you want to ask is 100 horse 100 duck
sized horses or a horse sized duck the
answer is a horse sized duck you just
kill a horse sized duck 100 200 tough so
this is from captain phase oh wait hold
on it's got a load here there actually
is a thing called what rat baiting where
they used to have a dog flight a hundred
rats or something I don't know the
twenties were or the pre-industrial
revolution times were awful
alright here we go so that makes you
more yes three yep be okay and then it's
zero zero zero zero
yeah four zeros for the next one
zero zero
three-one okay 36 c0 there we go oh my
god says this situps while you're
waiting it's like it's gonna be healthy
yeah to visit ducks or horses or hostile
a-holes yeah uh Conan is really into a
couple games Ken he's into oh okay Oh
give it to me one more time what are
they before four yep d yep three yep
[Music]
double zero yeah what's up TJ mom jeans
31:36 c0 American been here we go
American pen blue melon hey thanks
you're cool too
thank you for joining us yes oh this is
food this is like scorch trials
how's our barometer like how much is it
like how much is it yeah which isn't
like the Maze Runner scorch trials the
maze is never over your test is never
over scorched trailer oh come on I knew
that was gonna be bad you're not playing
by the rules of the may is squiddy
oh this is gonna be fun
clear the way
you know I use more than one up a big
actually a big actually won't help me
here because favorite color gray means
good mental illness yeah mr. gray means
minecraft loves minecraft yeah he loves
Angry Birds I'm not paying attention
sorry it's hard to scorch trials and
this or tell think he's played halo he
likes I mean it doesn't really have time
to play a lot of games on his own he
likes a game called read books about US
presidents which is a fun game enjoy
that's one of the best favorite games do
[Music]
geez this is sad if I can't get this the
next time we're just gonna go on the
struggle is real Jack productions you're
right you guys were playing Super Mario
maker today because Mario turned 30
yesterday owner of Mario Mario feels
like he has gray hair wonderful I was
gonna get gray hair if he just is gonna
stay dark his whole life I got to meet
day the creator of Mario which is kind
of cool a couple years ago yeah that was
really cool it's really nice guy I got
to ask them some questions about Mario
ice to chill dude you know yeah that was
really fun
he's a celebrity Jesus Blair pull it
together I know if you're allowed to
talking about some tongs but your honest
opinion on Trump and/or Deez Nuts
why would he want to talk about politics
that's my question
but I think deez nutz is really gonna
change yeah make America great again
exactly here we go the thing is here's
what I understand plumbers make a lot of
money why does mario want to do all this
stuff like saving the world like dude
you could charge so what's gonna Sunday
you're charging time and a half like
mario is probably super rich and doesn't
need to do any of this stuff here we go
I got time this just right that's right
hey turn slaves he's not into video
games money can't buy a princess ooh a
PC man says you're right but it can buy
a lot of daisies if you know what I'm
saying daisy is another character we got
it we did it we did it we did it that
counts he's saving his girlfriend money
won't do that is he saving his
girlfriend does she really want to be
saved that's my question I asked to you
for those of you who have played braid
you know what I'm talking about
but you know what it's we only know
Mario side of the story and he could be
an unreliable narrator we don't know
maybe was she actually taken by Bowser
or did she just leave Mario as Mario is
an a-hole and now he's like trying to
steal her back and kidnap her from
Bowser maybe she's happy Impostors
Castle I'm saying let's play abalzer
Wars is called Bowser's family home all
right oh this is gonna be good Russia
Russian guy 92 probably been to Bayonne
New Jersey right yeah what is it five
three three three zero zero zero zero
zero three one eight six
all right so I asked yeah maybe surreal
chemist says maybe it's Li Jie's
girlfriend but I didn't see the rest of
that it's Luigi's girlfriend could be
Bowser get ya
Bowser's not having affair with her
Simmons dude I'm sick of course not
found I'm saying maybe Bowser and and
the princess actually have true love and
Mario's being like an a-hole and getting
into it this is set five three three
three zero zero zero zero eight 600-lb
FBI list it was dexian there we go
[Music]
peach set the whole thing up was part of
elaborate fetish what did I study in
college I studied telecommunications but
I did I did a hey it's American ray
thanks American ray for your course
Bowser's family home um I guess Jesus
I studied telecommunications at college
but really what got me this job was like
I was an intern and man you a-holes
making bad guys in the stuff
whoops whoops I got an internship here
which is great and I did a lot of
television and a lot of television and
radio in college as well as like F and
that's where I got the experience I made
a lot of stuff in my own which I still
do which everyone should be doing out
there which is how ya how I got the job
I was just a great intern
but yeah we're huge showbiz isn't a
secret I mean it's just you know if you
it is kind of like what Conan said if
you work to kind and work hard good
things will happen what am I supposed to
do there what am I supposed to do jump
on those things om seven secret oh hello
sexy people how you doing pretty good I
got I'm not good T dominant we know how
Conan treats his interns varrock do you
like Conan I hear that he likes little
girls well he likes all people little
girls included um but yeah Cohen's the
man he's super nice do you like how you
tried to troll me and say something bad
but doesn't work yeah nice try celebs
fascinate me because they're ridiculous
oh come on now I'm screwed
no you this guy's this guy's heating
bill has to be over the moon it's gonna
be bad miss me don't want it oh jeez
those remind me of like SpaghettiOs
YouTube gaming is tweeting about hey
awesome hey thanks YouTube gaming for
the air for the shoutout
today if you guys are just joining us we
are playing Super Mario maker because
yesterday
Mario turned 30 a young 30 30 years
young and so we are playing your Maps
that you guys have made on Super Mario
maker and so far you guys are doing a
great job what are some of our favorite
maps that we played so far great
adventurers great Coco's nightclub
Coco's nightclubs fantastic take the
Bowser flying thing blue melon set Oh
could I oh if I kill that guy then I can
fly in it all right make sense
oh geez oh no now I threw it all off
no no this is not gonna go well decent
is yes this is live ye or yes you're
older than Mario you don't care about
you you don't care about Bowser's
heating Billy he's setting his fish on
fire that's true it's kind of a crappy
bit maybe that's how he likes fried fish
maybe that's just how he cooks perfect
nailed it I'm doing great so far
[Music]
fake-ass flying thing let's go yeah here
we go
how far can I take it I can't get in
here I can't I gotta get out of this
thing this thing gonna blow up on me
what are these do
yikes it's gonna come back
yep I see I see that didn't go so well
did it Blair would games do you like to
play sunny to menu well let's see last
night I played layers of evil on Steam
which is pretty fun it's about an insane
painter it's kind of like PT mixed with
a mix of painting I could play a lot of
alien isolation which is great what else
are they playing lately I've been
playing a lot of Jesus that's have been
playing I don't know a lot of stuff
levels of fear yeah sorry levels of fear
levels of fear sorry what did I say
Oh levels of fear is it not I think it
sounds layers of fear I said levels
layers no its levels it's layers of fear
not evil exactly
Oh somebody somebody just gave us a
relaxing one a relaxed a code for a
relaxed I can and you know what after
all the after all these really stressful
levels I could use a relaxing level
oh this fire this is so stressful
all right one more uh what @vx 14 what
is the next clue schemer gonna be I
can't tell you but it is gonna be
amazing when it's gonna be it'll
probably be next week because we're
shooting one on Wednesday I'm actually
super nervous about the one on Wednesday
but I think it'll go well you guys will
see it's gonna be pretty epic we got a
couple pretty clearly at the close
gamers coming up also we're thinking
about maybe doing like a Halloween one
like we did last year
with a couple of games so let us know if
you guys like particular scary games got
alright what's the other one it's gonna
be metal gear I don't know killing
killing PC no nose lets you walk in the
park
you're afraid that do the relaxing one
supreme yes yes I agree I love it
I use the oculus rift I have it was
awesome alright so oh I I applauds
actually played oh I actually beat until
dawn on my own on my own personal twitch
channel over a couple weeks that was
super fun and it was great it looked
gorgeous as like hayden Panettiere rami
malek all these awesome people in it I
had a really fun time I beat zero levels
not true I beat the gauntlet the only
level I've ever done
ah Rennicks knows it takes for us to
shoot one show we like to shoot live to
tape which means it takes about an hour
to shoot one show unless things get
screwed up which probably they don't one
direction 6b we did play Mad Max it was
awesome it was awesome we'll be playing
also Mad Max in the future it was really
fun but yeah one of the really fun
things is we have this thing on Team
Coco called scraps and sometimes you
know what you basically see when you
watch our show when it's broadcast is
basically what we've taped but sometimes
crazy things will happen like a fire
alarm will go off or something insane or
a comedy that won't go well backfire
oh I thought you said the sort of
relaxing
I died immediately oh I get it you were
kidding relaxing my ass but there is
there is a thing called scraps we do
which is stuff that's cut out of the
show is we put up online for you guys to
see so I think good things are Langhorne
slim there's a thing that didn't make
air but was but was super fun and funny
and TIG Notaro who's a friend of ours
they were really funny that didn't make
air but so you can see that on our
scraps today so oh my god dude how am I
gonna do this splatoon level relaxing is
a sit Ebola course what does that mean
music Luna cow my name is Coco before
his voice he stole it from me well
actually Tom Hanks stole from you
because Tom Hanks named Conan
Wow
this level is terrible alright we're not
gonna play this level yeah supreme gala
I agree this is impossible and not
relaxing but thank you for making it
thank you for letting us know about it
will I play Super Mario 64 please reply
not today but hopefully in the future
we'll play a little slips from Rio 64
[Music]
yeah see the trampoline one okay hey
that's negative six out of ten I did
there we go courses yep cb4 zeros yep
keep going double 0 30 we're here every
Monday it's not our first time no this
is not our first time this is actually
this might be the year anniversary of us
tournament when emailing you know let's
have a year anniversary party next week
alright alright find the real Jersey
yeah yeah Holly fudge 579 my name is
blade this is Beth over in the corner
we'll Becton yo and Jason O'Malley hey
that's right we're here every monday at
noon pacific time to 1:30 and yes
sometimes celebs show up sometimes conan
shows up you never know who's gonna show
up let me try that one more time what is
it trampoline level a gear Dogu yeah I
love watching let's play that's a great
YouTube serious d9 yep
cb4 zeroes double zero
thirty a a thirty-five
all right search of course whoo I love
it also guys after after we finished
today please tweet your codes at us with
hashtag Monday melee and then we can
keep track of all so we can play and and
if Conan comes did we could have me play
at a certain point to might be really
fun
how did the Playmate Resident Evil
session end video cut before the clip no
one's clothes came off especially not
mine because no one wants to see what's
under here it's gross ooh that's
American s press here we go it was great
we just played for a little while they'd
have a lot of time to play so we only
kind of got through that level oh my god
trampoline level yes this is awesome and
I died immediately sorry
here we go let's go Jesus it is cut you
know what it's weird it's kinda time it
he says
I'm trying Tokyo pimps
oh my god deceptively hard all right I'm
gonna make it past the first part with
the taken king I don't know what that is
what is the taken king cool so perfect I
can't I can't even beat this this is I
think I just need to go quick I got a
bucket man no playing around on these
trampolines
this is deceptively hard but I very very
fun level or not yeah I think you guys
are learning what I do oh I don't know
I'm not a big destiny player but maybe
it's because I don't have a lot of
friends and I think dusty is more fun
with the more friends you have yes hey
hey yo says that move right there sums
up my skill level yes it does very
nicely
I'll let Beth do this one McTavish does
do it
the buttons are this moves okay and then
I think I think she's a and B a jumps B
makes you run if you hold it down so you
can do it go Beth go Hey great to see
you too thanks for joining us I almost
did that wait what is B how do you go
higher well I like we have to time it
when you're jumping on the thing you
hold a try to hold it jump on the thing
and try to hold
I think it you cept it I mean you have
to jump as you're hitting the trampoline
I think try it again
this is bets hell by the way this is
better this down you got it
just try to go right go to the right you
want to go to the right guy should be
incorporating more buttons yeah thanks
animals in bed oh oh yes oh I did a
thing bad let's go somebody say thank
you you're thank you for that destiny
help whoo shady wants creeper willed to
do a level that's like will you want to
try a level get in here will Becton
everybody just a jumps and be kind of
speed we don't need that in this long a
jump yeah you know you didn't start them
again here is this the neighborhoods of
keep moving
yeah that's them again is that the
movies all right one more time
ooh here we go here we go yes we're
always killing it wait do it again do it
again
the Queen says hey will yeah we're not
getting Kramer we're not getting paid
Kramer probably said that Kramer from
yeah yeah Jack's got a ghost to cat and
create ghost account a mouse you wanna
try this on your own Valley get out here
you're gonna die oh you might not die
this time go go O'Malley's the best
gamer in the room yeah I got this
okay he's got this ah Klaus where Klaus
are playing
we're playing Wii U on Super Mario maker
because of Mario's nice bow he's killing
it Caesar clown Jordan won't come in
here he would he refuses he refuses
creepers name I got a redeem the creeper
yeah yeah it's not a very long one okay
there we go
plum says wills the sexiest dude nice
shiny was going alright alright we're
gonna play it let's play one more we got
another fan one here I think you know
the key is I don't bear trampoline we
had to finish that off strong all right
yes
Jordan is actually like that in real
life collectible I don't know if gonna
play yeah yeah I don't know if I'll ever
play counter-strike maybe awesome thank
you for retweeting our life thing we
appreciate it
alright here we go alright last course
last course we're almost down here guys
again just because we're gonna play a
little only one more course today
doesn't mean we have it we're not gonna
play more courses in the future so
please tweet at Team Coco hashtag Monday
melee with your super mario maker code
and we all lot collect them this was
designed by a reasonable man and will
likely be enjoyed by all who all right a
reason a reasonable course finally over
these two old cars 0 0 1 b 5 1 7 a this
is from hey it's abraham all right man
we'll see how reasonable you are I
remember the relaxing level which is a
so is nightclub the current yeah I think
yeah Team Coco nightclub is the current
leader of awesome ones here exactly what
are you gonna play the viewers next week
we'll play it viewers how about that we
have Lemieux's in the past
here we go a lot of fun oh cool level a
lot of fun we're having reasonable man
my ass here we go cool level a lot of
fun a boner life I think they put up
there alright here we go great oh great
love that boner life that's important
that's important for any a reasonable
man eh this just keeps getting harder I
feel like Oh - oh I see their trials oh
man
now we're in trouble how was it where's
the beer fridge that's a good great
where is the beer fridge let's guy get
down here I don't think so
[Music]
I'm gonna try it again we got - we got
this round - this is the Scorch Trials
Lalo's I love it I love I'm sure a
Nintendo super happy that you could just
put boner life finally we made something
we're Super Mario can have the words
boner like that I'm not being careful at
all in this game all right I'm gonna try
why's why fatality bone because he likes
bone early I'm boned dude I get it
dude slant for everyone asking shlonsky
will not play I have asked him every
single week we've done Monday Malin he
always says no he'll come in and and
like but he refuses to play he just
won't do it I'll tell you what a boner
is that I can't busting these blocks so
many won't hurt you boner it's kind of
crazy that what was that is it silver
spoons or growing pains there was a
character named boner how do you think
how do they get that past the somebody
else boner life Conan will yeah if you
go into our past broadcasts or you look
on our on our YouTube channel
yes Conan has played a number of times
with us out here he actually usually
comes in to be honest but this is our
first day back from break so I feel like
he's means to get he's a concentrate on
the show today all right here we go
something I'm stoned and it's making it
really hard to keep up with all your
different conversations yeah well I'll
try to slow your what do we think I can
just jump
these bullets are not fun
that was a bad idea
coulda gone better that's pretty good I
bet we ever play super smash brothers
melee on Monday melee oh we have and we
we shall again probably I'm gonna guess
alright yeah next week we'll play
something that we're gonna play with you
guys
bone got so boned magic mitts is super
relaxing
alright last time here we go
I do love the game Super Meat Boy
because it feels like a more insane
Super Mario Brothers god damn it I can
never quite get the trampoline thing I
hope you don't bone us next week exactly
stems as I ever was the trampoline thing
is tough alright here we go here we go
ready
boned life loving that bowed life but
life let's do it how many to many are
there how many levels are there who made
this level answer for your crimes
hey it's Abraham how many levels are
there of this that's my question I want
it all close I am I don't say if Lee did
enough to watch Kohner anymore
I had a baby but I still watch the blaze
stuff there you go
perfect let's see I played anymore my
stuff is way later
here we go here we go carefully
carefully carefully there's ten trials
ten trials Jesus only made it through
five ten trials for the 10w sins Mario
is committed what's your what this is
like seven
what is this like is this gluttony
what's this sin no it's like if you hit
jump at the right time you jump higher
but I can never quite get it right all
right here we go
they've been washing clothes gamers and
Star Wars Kinect was that Wow that was
the first one thank you for watching
that that's cool that wasn't even on the
show that was online now oh my god here
we go
bullet City give me a give me a big give
me a big hey dick all right here we go
it doesn't shoot if I stand next to it
right well ladies and gentlemen I think
that's gonna do it for today
that's it
we got boned we got bowed thank you for
joining us and we will see you next
Monday where we're gonna play with you
guys I don't think we're gonna play
Mario maker though but but keep an eye
out on our on our Twitter and Facebook
pages for we'll be playing and again
please tweet at us with your code
hashtag Monday melee and we'll put it
into the system so we can play in the
future and hopefully get Conan to play
one year level so that would be super
fun thanks all for joining us I bet
we're asking the chat Jason O'Malley
will backed in Monday melee we're back
baby make sure you tune in Dakota
tonight at 11:00 on CBS see you guys
later bye
[Music]
you